hello everyone first let me say thank
you to all of
our audience uh thank you for coming to
our panel on
women and nlp and conversational ai
my name is yan liu i'm a personal
scientist at amazon
working at the alexa ai i used to be a
faculty member for
quite a long time i have been working at
alexa ai for
one year and nine months-ish um the
problem i have been working on at
amazon include one different speech nlp
dialogue related problems
um so in this panel we have invited a
few
female scientists at amazon for work in
nlp
and today in today's panel we're going
to cover topics like
their career path importance of women in
nlp or stanley in general
we'll talk about opportunities for women
in these areas
and discuss some mentorship working at
amazon
etc um before i introduce our panelists
i just want to give a high level quick
overview um
for some work going on at amazon related
to nlp
we have a lot of teams that work on
different kinds of nlp
problems and this may be of particularly
interesting to
people who are listening to this panel
right now um
for example i come from alexa ai and
alexa
we work on a lot of speech related
problems including speech recognition
text-to-speech
wake work detection speech authorization
emotional recognition
and so on and in an opinion dialogue
we work on the entire nlp pipelines
uh including uh sentence topic
classification entity recognition
interlinking summarization translation
search uh in dialogue and we also work
from guaranteed dialogue all the way to
open domain
search above chat conversations um
and also in teams like in aws
they work on pretty much similar
problems all the way from speech to nlp
to translation dialogue problems
the difference between aws and alexa is
for alexa the technology is used in
products that serve alexa customers
aws the customers are like business or
enterprise
another example is amazon.com the
e-commerce
site there uh analogy technology is
needed for
problems like uh understanding user's
query and send a product description
users review document understanding
such that users can achieve their goals
so that gives you a very high level
overview for
some of the work going on with its nokia
amazon
next we're going to go around the table
and then do
a quick introduction um i'm going to let
all the panelists do their own
introduction
um so if everyone can say your name
uh how long we've been working at amazon
uh what do you do
um or how does your background help you
to be
successful that will be good and we can
go around in
alphabetical order i guess um so and i
will start with you
okay cool um yeah so hi i'm anna anna
curry
um i am an applied scientist at aws
um and i've been working at amazon about
a year and a half
and i work on the amazon translate
service so in my role
i do research in machine translation
really anything to do with machine
translation modeling but especially
quality and customization and as far as
my background so i
came here right after my phd and i did
my phd in machine translation so
it's kind of this is the role that i
trained for um
but also before going back to school and
transitioning to nlp
i was a ux designer um which i think
is really helpful for an amazon context
because
um i learned kind of how to put myself
in the customer's shoes and
really you know see things through the
customers eyes which is important for us
here at amazon as well
next one hi everyone
i'm i'm mohanji and i have been at
amazon for a little more than one year
now as a amazon scholar
i still keep my full-time job at ui ucs
professor
so in academia i have been doing
research on information nutrition for
almost two decades since i was a
undergraduate student
and i applied my research to many
applications
that are related to open general domains
and now i'm just hoping that i can test
the techniques on real world
applications
so amazon is the best choice for me and
i'm now
contributing to many research areas
including
multi-lingual multimedia entity event
recommendation
knowledge driven generation and skill
discovery
in different groups under alexa
maryam uh hi everyone my name is mariam
fazel zerandi
i've been at amazon for a little over
four years now since i joined amazon
i've been working on different aspects
of data-driven dialogue management
we're building techniques and tools to
help alexa have more natural dialogues
with end users
but also help developers build uh rich
multi-turn conversational experiences
i'm very passionate about the work we do
i think we work on
very hard problems which are ambiguous
but humans are surprisingly very good at
um i've been working in this area for
over eight years now
since i got my phd in computer science
from university of toronto
and i would say like my background helps
me
protocol research and also innovate on
behalf of our customers
yeah hi like anna i'm also a scientist
in aws ai
i've been at amazon for about four years
now
and i work in the area of conversational
ai or dialogue systems
with various teams at amazon um and
beyond to your question on
you know do we feel that our background
has really helped us
um i think it does you know having a
background in
nlp and machine learning from cmao go
tartans
helps me understand customers pain
points and
you know gives me a wider
cross-disciplinary view
on what is possible and you know what is
not possible
there's not always a one-size-fits-all
solution for our customers so connecting
um you know solutions in the literature
and building on top of them
with my background in nlp and applied ml
um
helps me think or build solutions that
are better suited for different customer
circumstances or needs
um yeah so hi everyone nice to meet all
of you
okay oh that's good and i want to say
you want to thank you
to all of you for um coming to this
panel and we'll hear your thoughts on
a few different topics uh so the first
one i'm going to discuss is
importance of women in nlp
conversational ai or stem
in general um the first thing i want to
touch on is
involvement in the broader science
community
so this is from niko some of us just
participated in nicole 2021 i know some
of you have papers and you presented
your research work
um and i uh were also on the organizing
committee serving as
area chair or senior year chairs in fact
i
recently served as one of the program
chairs for
emanopie 2010 which was
just different echo so
speaking of getting involved in the
broader science community
i want to hear your thoughts on this
issue how important has that been in
developing
your career and maybe we can start with
hong kong because she is very active in
the science community
um you have any thoughts from yeah
thanks young
so neko is one of my favorite
professional organizations
uh actually i'm currently a secretary of
uh neko
and um i have been helping all these
conferences
every year so for this year i'm giving a
keynote
at necco some school and also i'm giving
a conference tutorial
um and the title is deep learning on
graphs for nlp
just in case anyone is interested in
watching our videos
and my students are presenting eight
papers
so i have been also serving as a senior
chair
for information suggestion area and i
was the program committee co-chair for
neko 2018 three years ago
along with another program committee
co-chair
who is also a woman and a conference
general chair who is also a woman
so i generally found that when women
serve as the
leadership roles they tend to be more
likely thinking about women candidates
other women candidates
for you know keynote speakers or elder
chairs and so on
so i really think in the nlp community
we have already many women
who have been very actively serving as
chairs and presidents
but i still think that we need to be
more successful
as leading researcher and also producing
high quality work
so for example if we look at the
current government project pi meetings
still normally 90 of the pis are men
and so one of my main career goals is to
train
a very big team of women principal
investigators
and then send them to this kind of
meetings and i hope they can
you know lead research either in
academia or in
industry so that could
serve as the fundamental way to change
the culture
jasmine do you have anything to add
maybe from
being in this industry adding a
different perspective
getting involved in the broader um
science community
yeah sure um so i think as industry
leader it's critical for amazon
you know to engage with scientists um or
you know experts outside
amazon um and share thoughts about
uh real-world problems that our
customers come to us with
and um you know collaborate with the
broader science community
to invent solutions around those
problems so as a result i think it is
very important for us to be involved in
conferences
uh you know be it at writing papers
reviewing papers
or organizing workshops and conferences
um
bringing attention to these customer
pain points or um
you know problems that are more relevant
to amazon will help the
nlp or you know machine learning
community advance in those directions of
research
um that are i think interest you know to
uh to amazon
at the same time i think engaging in
external conferences will also
help raise awareness of all the
cutting-edge research work that we do at
amazon
and i think that will also in turn then
help
us recruit and hire a top talent
i think that's my opinion yeah
um anyone maryam yeah i would say um
i agree with what was said about the
importance of being involved in the
broader scientific community
at amazon we do encourage our scientists
to publish and review papers
and also help organize conferences and
workshops
for example here at knackle this year
amazon teams have several papers
our team specifically we have a paper on
alexa conversations
which presents a data driven approach
for building task oriented
dialogue systems this approach provides
an out of the box support for uh
different natural
conversation phenomena and makes it much
easier for developers to build
uh rich conversational um experiences uh
i
i would say um like like rashmi said
publishing such works helps bring
attention to the problems
that real customers have and together
you know
us working with researchers outside of
amazon we can push the state of the art
in voice first experiences and other
areas
um okay so this panel is on
women in an opioid stem in general and i
want to hear
what your experience what does it
look like to work as a woman in an oval
stem
at amazon some of you can share
experience as a female
scientist or even female leader working
at these large
companies or corporations great
um anna
you're you're exactly whether you're new
whether because you are
you have worked at amazon for over a
year um
yeah so what does it look like
yeah sure i guess so i can i can give my
perspective as someone who's pretty new
um so you know i i've enjoyed
being i've enjoyed being at amazon and
i've enjoyed being a woman in nlp at
amazon
um i um right now actually i'm on a team
where half of the scientists are women
so that's kind of
um i think fun you know it's kind of
positive because
uh like in grad school or in internships
i didn't necessarily always have that
um so so i think that's been a really
positive thing and
and also something um that i think for
me
as someone who's very new um with
something at amazon
that's really helped me is the writing
culture here so um
you know i don't know i don't know if
this is a woman thing or a new to the
field or maybe it's just like an anna
thing but
um i kind of get really uh
intimidated speaking up in meetings
sometimes um
and amazon a lot of times the way a
meeting will work is
uh instead of you know everyone's
speaking up all at once um we start by
reading a document
and writing comments on the document um
and i think
that's really helpful because um i'm i
don't have to be on the spot
to express myself the right way i can
think about how
i want to to write my comments and
things and so i think
um that's one one aspect of amazon
that's
been really helpful for me just kind of
to get more comfortable
speaking up within my career
um so do you have some
experience to share coming from academia
i want to work as
a scholar at amazon yes so i have been
fully enjoying the culture so far
in in this regard at amazon i have many
great women leading researchers to look
up to such as young yourself
and uh dr dave kakanito
both of you have been my role models
since i was a student
i have been actively recommending other
women pg students to do internship at
amazon as well
and i have received the first support
from everyone
so currently i from my own group i
have two women pg students they are
doing internships
right now
yeah it is working working with us
yeah yeah we did so thank you let's do
this
are we going to talk about students and
interns a lot of later
um let's hear what that what other
um say about this topic
um brush me and you want to add anything
yeah i can add a few more points
uh yeah so uh you know going to surveys
i think that's something that we
typically bring up right
um so according to surveys that have
been performed and i think this
these surveys are done regularly um we
do notice that you know men have
dominated stem
occupations um the representation of
women has increased over the last few
years so that is that is a good thing
right so overall i think the trend is a
good sign this trend is a good sign
and of course i have been in meetings
where you know
i've been the only woman in a room uh
with about 10 to 12 men
and sometimes it's even more than that
um but i don't like to consider these
situations as limitations for our
success
um or a reason for women to be you know
discouraged about um
but something we should all work to
improve um
at amazon we encourage every person to
be vocal
and be able to share their thoughts um
and opinions right so
um i've started taking you know
conscious steps
um not just me but my fellow employees
as well
um and i'm sure you are doing that too
um so for example in meetings if i do
notice people
men or women right shying away from
providing their perspectives
we try to give them a chance to share
their opinions
while at the same time we try to make
sure that you know we don't sound too
heavy-handed
so yeah
you know that's good suggestion
something we should all be doing
um so we talked about that we are at a
different state of our korean and uh
weather started
much later than what or me um
so maybe we can talk about the world of
mentorship a little bit
um can all of you or some of you
talk about the importance of mentorship
in your career
um how have other women
impacted your growth or your success
throughout your career
or maybe you have already acted as a
mentor yourself
um if you can share some of your
experience that you did
and i know you don't want to be called
on the spot
but let's start with you
okay it's okay i've practiced so um
yeah so regarding mentorship i think um
up until now for me personally all of my
kind of
like official mentors have been men um
and that goes back to what what rashmi
pointed out that
it's a male dominated field so i think
statistically that's not too unlikely um
but you know that's not to say that i
haven't learned a lot from them and and
really benefited from their mentorship
um but as far as you know women that
have helped me
um you know on my trajectory in the
field um
i think i've been lucky to have uh some
female managers including my manager
right now um
and also i think you know like panels
like this or
as hung was talking about you know
people women in amazon who are in
roles that i want to maybe be in someday
i think
it's just really uh inspiring at least
for me you know relatively new in my
career to be able to look at
um all of you and and other women who
are
um already in the place where i want to
be i think that's really
um it's great to have to have these role
models even
though i you know may not work as
closely with them
um and also you know one thing that's
that has really helped me um
within the nlp field is the um
the widening and nlp uh workshops so
um i think my first kind of um
workshop conference experience of my phd
was at a widening nlp workshop and
it was just a really positive way of
of getting started in the field you know
it's a very supportive environment so
i would recommend you know any any woman
who's watching this to or
or any person in who's at all
under-represented
in nlp to to look them up and um
participate in their workshops yeah
that's indeed a very good initiative
from the community
anyone want to volunteer
yeah i can i can i can say next
i i actually echo a nice experience
about this because i also have many more
men than women
who have mentored and supported me
officially throughout
my career um many of these
men are more like my teacher like
teacher like a father like friend that's
a chinese thing um
including my own former pg advisor
and professor chang at columbia
university
he is now also a amazon scholar
and my current manager dot prince
he's a vp of amazon and all of them are
feminists i would say and also um
most of them have daughters i don't know
whether that matters but uh all of them
are feminists
and they have encouraged me and provided
me
tremendous support and encouragement so
i also have really enjoyed my
collaboration with the
with them and they learned a lot but on
the other hand i have been very very
fortunate to have
many great women amazing women leaders
who have inspired me and supported me
even not unofficially but great support
so that include again you know my dear
sister friend yang
and dilek and also professor kathy
mcqueen who is
also i'm a scholar and uh
for example daughter radha maharaj
sierra who is a
professor at the university of michigan
the isl president
um so i'm having just trying hard to
follow
them and try my very best to help and
also support younger women
following their past yeah so
everything has been amazing to me i mean
in this aspect
actually i i like um working with both
men
and women mentors i think they have
different
features that uh um has been
always very critical in my career path
yeah thank you for saying that
yeah i i agree with um what anna and
hank said i've also had like many
mentors and i also mentored others
throughout my studies and and career and
i've learned
a lot from both about the people i've
mentored
who mentored me and the people i
mentored um
i would say that i go i have like
different mentors
who i go to for different things i may
discuss different
topics with each with each person some i
may talk about like
career opportunities and growth whereas
with others i may mostly
do brainstorming or ask or give a
feedback on technical work
so that you know both i can grow and you
know i can help others
also grow as as scientists
i think it's always good to get
different perspectives on an issue and i
think
mentorship provides provides this
opportunity to get feedback from others
and also experience
learn from experiences that other people
have uh one thing i would say that i
like about amazon is that it
is that it provides a lot of tools and
resources
for people to find mentors and also find
opportunities to mentor others
and also um it provides a lot of like
mentorship opportunities to female
interns in particular
to help them with their career plans and
to help them broaden their network
yes i totally agree with everybody you
know mentorship
plays a crucial role uh like everybody
said
um it's it's so important right
and i have mentors both uh within and
outside amazon
and i think it somehow even connects to
the previous question that we had
right um i do try to
mentor as many women as possible um
again this is both inside as well as
outside amazon
um i think you know mentorship need not
always be work related
um we can also be around family or other
personal matters too
you know whatever mentees need to be
successful right um
i find that learning from others
experiences
and listening to different perspectives
um
helps me you know make better decisions
um
so i think in the end we shouldn't shy
away from asking for guidance and i
think that's something we as women
uh tend to do um yeah i think we should
always go look for mentor
mentors and you know make use of that uh
well
yeah there are people ready to help us
out so yeah
we should ask for help
yeah um my experience may be a little
bit different uh two of
my phd advisors are women and all
a lot of the collaborators i have had in
the past that two decades
are female or women weather researchers
so they have been super super supportive
of my
um career and i really appreciate that
and like everyone said
whether whether it's men or women
whether we all benefit a lot
from our mentorship and i hope we can
all
pay it forward and then we'll do um
as much as we can in supporting the next
generation scientists
i think that's what everyone is doing
you know
um too many amazing female students in
the past
now okay um so maryam want to touch on a
little bit on what
opportunities at amazon or other places
and
that's what we want to discuss in the
next topic um so opportunities for women
in um stem and here maybe with nrp
specifically we all know
there are a lot of water recruiting
efforts and there are
all kinds of programs that uh support
female interns or full-time engineers or
scientists
whether it's in a broader science
community and also at amazon it's the
same thing
um and we talked about working at amazon
how it feels like
working as a woman at amazon but maybe
what uh we can go over um one more time
and
if you can talk about it what do you
like the most about amazon
or what you are most excited about that
will
give us people a better sense of
some good things going on at amazon
um but still do i have like out there so
anna yeah sure um
so i think what what i
think is really cool about working at
amazon is um
i think just i thought what people have
already said is the fact that you're
working
on real problems that you know
real customers actually care about um
you know i just i find it very
energizing to know that i'm doing
something
because it can actually improve the
customer experience
and you know i'm working on a product or
a service that
the customer will actually use and i
think that's it's very motivating and
also i think
you know from a research standpoint just
kind of um echo what what rashmi mariam
already said
that that kind of informs research
questions that we do
so you know it's the fact that we're
working on real world problems is both
motivating and really kind of um
inspiring for our research
yeah totally agree with that i wasn't
like i said that early when i come
from academia background and that's one
thing we notice the difference between
uh being an academia and then these
companies everything is
customer-driven applied research a
product can orientate a lot of things
and i guess phone probably shares the
same
experience do you want to talk a little
bit
yeah exactly so my favorite part is also
that we are able to work on interesting
real world applications
even though i'm only doing 20 of my time
for
for this scar work i i really really
enjoy
that part of this this uh
all these projects very interesting you
can see the real world
applications and i also really enjoy
crosstalking collaborate
collaborative culture at amazon so the
boundary between groups is really
vague i can work with anyone i like i
think i i really enjoy that part as well
oh mario yeah um i i really like that we
work on heart problems at large scale
and like anna and hang and yang you said
these problems like bring benefits to
customers they're customer focused
and that we also like work with uh
scientists engineers ux designers to
bring these research ideas
uh that we work on to uh to production
um i also like that amazon is a large
company and it makes it very easy to
find people who have a similar interest
so you can like brainstorm with come up
with like new ideas with new initiatives
and also
you know have reading groups with which
i find very enjoyable
yeah i will probably you know list a
leadership principle here
amazon's leadership principles um so one
of my favorite ones
you know has been think pink um as we
all know amazon encourages its employees
to think
um you know of bold directions um right
and to
also see customer pain points or
problems as opportunities to create
bigger solutions
right so i think this applies all the
moto scientists at
amazon uh you know thinking about uh
think big
um has allowed me to be more creative
and solutions we build
um not just me i mean all of
the whole of amazon so listening to
customers problems and building
solutions that
best cater to their needs you know even
if the solution is hard or you know it
might take several years to build
right um this is something that i have
you know really enjoyed and i always
feel excited about
it's good um thanks for sharing this
um i know some of the audience who are
listening to this panel must
be students um so let's talk a little
bit about
internship um i suppose many of you have
worked
with interns if you can share your
experience
about working with the interns and if
you have any suggestions otherwise
given to some of the audience who are
students
or hypothetically if you could go back
to a time when you were student
what would you say to yourself um
let's do one
um maybe and i guess
okay sure yeah um so yeah i've
i um so i've been here now this is my
second summer at amazon so i worked with
interns last summer and i am doing it
again this summer and
i i mean i think it's really enjoyable
to work with interns i think
you know they they um come with a lot of
ideas and they're
very energetic and very creative and so
i i think it's
one of one of the best parts of my job i
hope the interns have a similar
similarly enjoyable experience working
with me um
so um yeah i think um
one of the really cool things about
working with interns too is that um
uh you know when when they when we
think of projects to work on with them
um
the the goal is to think of
forward-looking projects so
um uh you know projects that maybe
aren't going to um go into the
the service immediately but things that
we want to do in the future
um i think i may have lost connection
for a second
yeah you're back no okay
um i don't know where i left off but um
i guess i'll i'll answer the the the
question about um
advice um if i could give advice to
myself
as a student or to interns or other
students i think i would say um
don't be afraid to ask questions and i
think that's something also that that
rushed me said earlier
um you know sometimes i think people shy
away from asking questions because they
don't want to
bother someone or because they don't
want to look silly
um my advice is to not do that to ask as
many questions
as as pop into your head you know
people will always be happy to answer
yeah as always there are no stupid
questions especially from students
yeah um i guess you gave otherwise all
the time to students
but still go ahead i agree with
everything and i
young have said um i think my
observation so far is
the inter students can really focus on
very ambitious and publishable research
ideas
and in most cases they can do research
relevant to their dissertation
topic and um
we always try hard to inspire them to to
do more long-term research on these
topics
and then it's also a nice way to attract
them to join amazon later as a full-time
employee
um well i wish i was a student still i
mean
in the counter time right because we
have such a bigger community
and so many more opportunities um
so i would say the general advice is try
to be more ambitious
um look at a longer term rather than
just you know publish the few papers at
the next acl
um yeah and i'll focus some more
publishable things
there to do things different from the
mainstream i think that's my advice
i go next yeah okay all right yeah i've
also had many
interns uh while i've been working at
amazon and i also mentored interns
from other teams uh interns always
motivated and eager to learn so it's
really really fun uh working with them
and also
it's great seeing them grow over like
although like the internship
time is is very short it's usually like
three months but it's
it's in it's like you you see them the
interns grow over this time and
and i find that uh enjoyable i would say
that
um internships also bring benefit for us
that they allow us to do
longer term research and also kind of
go beyond the immediate research needs
that we have for immediate customer
problems my advice to interns would be
that i encourage them to not just focus
on their projects but
take the advantage of the opportunity to
interact with
others learn about other projects that
others are working on and also
learn about like customer problems to
give them ideas to
you know uh to do more like other
types of research uh yeah that would be
my advice to it to interns
yeah um so i think i mean i've had
interns as well
um the experience has been great um you
know interns come with such creative
ideas you know like what william said
hangs it on i said
you know i agree with all that um know
it also brings a
strong research ethic i think this
combined with allowing them to think
big um and to be vocal uh it not only
creates
an environment you know that fosters
creativity
that is important for our products and
services but also
um you know it ensures you know we
provide an exceptional
internship experience um and um you know
this has already shown so many of our
interns end up joining amazon after they
graduate
so that's proved that this you know
environment is attracting
good and top talent um if i have to go
back
you know to when i was a student
i would tell myself to take on
challenging projects
um and to not shy away from the
complexity of the
problem yeah so i'm putting myself as a
student and you're trying to answer this
okay yeah i hope they will benefit from
some of these suggestions
um so at the beginning i mentioned
briefly what's going on at amazon
related to nlp
um now when we are close to the end of
this panel maybe we can hear from
all of you this is also one of the
questions
um that were pre-submitted um so people
are asking what is new and
exciting and up here at amazon and how
can you overcome barriers to be
successful
um does anyone want to join in
i can stop because my answer will be
quite short
because i'm only working 20 of my time
uh so to me the most exciting direction
is to discover
knowledge automatically from
multi-source data
and then use the knowledge to make all
these deep learning frameworks more
intelligent
uh as of uh how to how to
um break the barrier or tackle the
challenges
my general advice is always like try to
consider yourself as a driver
um when you're on a road trip instead of
the passengers uh sitting in the back
seat
sleeping um but at least try to wash the
gps for the driver
so that means that we should always have
a courage to do some creative research
that we have passion for even though you
know some of those ideas or topics are
not the most popular ones
um yeah that's it
yeah i i would say like the teams at
amazon are working on a broad range of
topics related to language understanding
and voice-based experiences yang
mentioned some of these
uh topics at the beginning uh i can't
list all of them here but
i would say like whatever your interests
are you can find and
find a team and collaborate with them on
that i do recommend
people to check out the amazon science
website and you know it has a
updated up-to-date list of the cool
research that's going on
in different areas at amazon yeah
totally agree yeah so work around you
know conversational ai you know
something that we've all
i think all of us you know have been
super excited about right
um at amazon we continue to improve all
our conversational bots
such as alexa aws chatbot and aws lex
to make everything at amazon easier and
faster for our customers
so common things to think about when
doing nlp research
include availability of data and they
need to respect
customer experiences and another thing
about you know overcoming barriers again
i'm going to go back to our stem
question right um again echoing what i
said earlier
i wouldn't like to consider
under-representation of women in stem
as a barrier but rather as an
opportunity or a challenge
to me and to us to encourage and support
more women to join this area
that seem to be a very good sentence for
us to end the conversation um
yeah i hope there will be more women who
will join the field and then we'll have
a good healthy
um kind of for the network and for
everyone to grow and the community will
get
larger and larger everyone will enjoy
their right
be the driver not just sitting on the
back seat that was
enjoying the ride um
yeah so i want to say thank you to all
of you for spending your time sharing
your experience and the perspective on
different
things related to new women working at
uh
either amazon or even other places and
giving people
suggestions advice and also
thanks to our audience who are listening
to this panel right now
um yeah with that i guess we can end
this
and if you have more questions or if you
need to know more information
you can send email reach out to
naco 2020 at amazon.com and of course um
i mentioned earlier we have
amazon.science page
where you can always get the latest news
announcement
papers uh work amazon
okay thanks everyone thanks
bye